we got this Twitter thread from Gonzalo
Lira this is the guy who was arrested in
Ukraine who has just recently gotten out
and is tweeting that he is seeking to
flee the country he says he was being
tortured in jail when he was arrested so
correctly I'm wrong you know you know a
lot about this limb he's an American
citizen correct he's an American
traditional right he's coach red pill
yeah yeah and and serge if you bring up
my pinned tweet is me asking the state
department about him
um in I think it was maybe like a month
ago or a couple months ago now
um and yeah I mean so that was when I
was at The Epic Times
um it didn't the the question didn't go
over so smoothly at The Epic Times I
don't know I don't know if I can get
into that too much well let's go through
this guy's Twitter thread he tweets
right now I'm about to I'm about to try
to get out of Ukraine and seek political
asylum in Hungary and I will also add
this was from 6 23 PM it's currently 9
24 p.m Eastern I'll check his Twitter to
see if he successfully crossed he
doesn't describe what happened to him he
says he broke no laws he was accused of
breaking no laws he was just reporting
on what was going on in Ukraine and it
made Ukraine look bad so they arrested
him he says my indictment explicitly
states that all I did was discuss
publicly known facts about the war the
epitome of free speech at a democracy
but zelenski's Ukraine is no democracy
It's A thieving corrupt murderous
gangster regime pretending to be polite
Western democracy he's right about that
and that's obvious because Ukraine has
always been that since the fall of the
Soviet Union
once arrested I was given documentation
assuring me that I was guaranteed the
right to contact my lawyers and loved
ones in fact I was blocked from calling
anyone even my lawyers and I was not
permitted to post bail he goes on to
describe that he was tortured
and let me let me uh once inside he's a
prison I was tortured in the two of the
four cells I was in by the other
prisoners guards never beat prisoners
they outsourced the torture one prisoner
actually apologized to me telling me he
had no choice he wasn't lying I
understood I got a cracked rib in my
first cell but it wasn't too bad the
worst stretch is my fourth cell he was
going to say that he was beaten for over
30 hours in sleep deprived the craziest
thing about this
and uh this is pretty brutal so you've
been warned he says at one point two
thugs held my head and used a toothpick
to scratch the whites of my left eye
while asking me if I could still read if
I had just one
not gonna lie that was unnerving
he goes on to say the US Embassy called
me three times but gave me nothing but
support in quotes empty bromides the
guard told me to remove my shirt he had
injury and bruising to his chest after
being beaten let's scroll down he wasn't
a mention that they found out he had
money he wasn't poor and they extorted
about seventy thousand dollars out of
him and he's lost about a hundred
thousand dollars
he says the conditions of his bail were
that he has to wear an ankle monitor
surrender his passports and not leave
the city of Kharkov much less the
country however after posting bail he
didn't get an ankle monitor and they
returned his passports he was going to
say that he was told by one guy they
were telling you to leave and then he
says he's he doesn't know so he's gonna
he decided he will die trying he rode
his motorcycle across Ukraine 1 400
kilometers in two days wow he said I'm
going to Hungary to ask for political
Asylum when I fail to show up in court
in Kharkov an arrest warrant will be
issued likely an international warrant
no doubt other EU countries will comply
like sheep returning me to serve five to
eight years in a prison labor camp
regardless of the fact the key have
arrested and imprisoned me for YouTube
videos for free speech what happened to
European democratic values well I'll
tell you Gonzalo Freedom Liberty and the
Constitution whatever you think you have
mean nothing in Warfare
they can tell you these things but it's
only when you're in a safe and secure
state where they allow it he says I'm
posting this thread just as I'm getting
to the Border checkpoint I'm also
posting videos on the two channels I
have access to the round table and
Gonzalo Lira again if you don't hear
from me in the next 12 hours well I'm on
my way to a labor camp wish me a luck
I'll pull up his account right now and
see if there's any updates uh that was
that that I believe that was the last he
posted oh my God maybe maybe he has some
replies
and uh we don't know if he made it that
was three hours ago
so this is a crazy story this is insane
and so this guy a little bit more about
him he was born in California
um he's a U.S citizen he's like a dual
citizenship in in Chilean and a lot of
people use that to discredit him but he
was born in the U.S he is a U.S citizen
he was in the past like a contributor
for Business Insider Zero Hedge
um he I I've talked to some people like
who I trust and they kind of they kind
of have like a bad opinion of him
they're like oh he's kind of a wacko but
at the end of the day he was
um he is a U.S citizen and all he was
doing that is correct when he says that
all he was doing was making YouTube
videos
um criticizing
the U.S uh NATO support for the Ukraine
war criticizing zelinski
um the U and I and so I asked the state
department about this a couple months
ago and and
um Matthew Miller the spokesman was just
like yeah you know we're aware this is
when he was still in jail he's like yeah
we're aware that he's that he's in jail
um we support free speech and I'm just
gonna leave it at that and I was like
well are you are you working to get him
released and he's like I'm just gonna
leave it at that and so clearly it
sounds like Gonzalo they probably had or
not well yeah they might have given the
order to get him arrested but it sounds
like he escaped prison right if I'm
reading that right no he was released
and they gave him back his passport oh
really yeah oh they released them gave
him his passport and said don't leave
however he was supposed to have an ankle
monitor and no password I see okay so
what he tweeted which is what we were
just reading is that someone told him yo
they're telling you to leave
but it could be a setup like he said he
leaves he takes us and he says I'm
getting out of here before and that's
what they use to get him
yeah what do you do other than that well
this is wild and like I'm I'm excited to
kind of ask the government about this
now because like this could change
it's an interesting story like it's
going to be interesting to see how like
our government reacts to this because
like are they going to acknowledge like
are they gonna are they gonna even
acknowledge this story because because
inherent to it is the fact that they've
been letting this U.S citizen rod in
prison for a couple months yeah they're
gonna ignore it yeah well yeah exactly
but I'm and I'm I hope to that I can ask
him about it um and and see what they
say but it's you know
yeah it's just crazy I mean he had the
wrong views and and so we allowed um or
even maybe directed our Ally to imprison
him uh for speech I remember when he was
insane when he was making those videos I
was like in my gut I thought wow this is
what is he doing he's in a war-torn he's
in the country that's at War right now
and he's talking crap about his own like
that doesn't go well for Citizens if
you're in a war like yeah right but but
the U.S should still stand up for the
principles free speech I agree with you
I I asked Thomas Massey that this
question it was not recorded but he
basically said the same thing he was
like well what was he doing over there
in Ukraine but it's like he he lived
there he lived there before the war
started he wasn't only reporting he
lived there so what's this that was his
home what's like the the set like if an
American goes to another country and
becomes a citizen have they not just
forgiven all their American rights they
no longer have American rights no He's
still in this country's rights he's not
as well he's a resident
yeah he's a citizen of the US a resident
of Ukraine but his his U.S citizen
rights don't apply to other countries
like you can't no no but when but when
U.S China is Right Chinese citizens but
go Go I mean listen to the Biden
Administration listen to the state
department whenever there's a U.S
citizen who I mean Brittany uh Brittany
Greiner like remember when she was
detained in Russia it was like all we
could talk about is like release him and
then um they traded the merchant the
Wall Street yeah and then the Wall
Street journalist The Wall Street
Journal journalist who was also
imprisoned in Russia I don't know if
he's still there but it's like with
those things we can't stop talking about
it because there's our adversaries
imprisoning our citizens this is our
Ally who we have a ton of Leverage over
um imprisoning our which says to me the
likely scenario is the Biden
Administration ordered his arrest
potentially potentially I asked a bunch
of people in Congress about this none of
zero zero out of maybe like 25 I would
just I would go in the halls of Congress
and outside zero out of 25 even knew he
was in jail how plausible does anybody
does everybody here think it is that the
U.S government ordered him to be
arrested how plausible on a scale of
zero hundred I'm gonna go ahead and say
100.
100 uh plausibility I'm not saying it's
definitively true yeah well so what I
would say is like at a minimum they they
probably gave the okay you know what I
mean like Ukraine's not just like an
American citizen so they probably at one
point had the US already arrested and
then Biden said yeah sure you want to
know why I think the US ordered it
because Barack Obama killed a 16 year
old American citizen and that wasn't the
only American citizen he killed so when
you can state
definitively that Barack Obama
murdered a 16 year old American citizen
a drone strike in Yemen then I'm like
yeah arresting a guy is like nowhere
near that bad I would say it is
plausible 100 that Biden could have
ordered that guy's arrest but I see Zero
evidence that he did so I'm not gonna
assume anything yeah exactly likely I
think no I am I'm gonna assume the U.S
and the US was involved because they
wouldn't get him out they wouldn't talk
about it they ignored it yeah it's too
we're too closely tightly knit with that
country to the us not to be well I agree
they were involved yeah I'm sure it was
discussed I'm sure they went and they
said hey you know Biden Administration
we got this guy he's an American what
should we do and they'll lock him up
yeah don't care probably because like
Biden probably doesn't care if people
are talking crap about the Ukraine it's
Biden you know he's checked out but
zielinski is like obsessively shutting
down radio stations into TV stations
that he shut down two of their biggest
three TV stations yeah he was doing that
before the war as well he was he was
sanctioning uh political opponents as
well as uh media Outlets that would
criticize him this was before the war so
yet another reason it's like why are we
why are we propping up this regime was
he doing that censorship with pressure
from the West
um I don't I don't know but he was doing
it yeah I don't I don't know where the
pressure came from but um
yeah so I you know he does have a
history of like not being a super
Democratic pro-freedom Guy and um yeah
this story in general is insane I mean I
hope uh
I hope Lyra I I wish him luck and I hope
this also injects into like the public
conversation of like wow the us just
like let this guy rot there and like I
hope it opens up a conversation about
like
you know that we're not really on the
side of of uh freedom and democracy in
this war thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time